hi this is pressure Locker in this video
I'm going to teach your way to
multiplying numbers by stacking them
let's say you want to multiply 12 by 13
so you all know you can do this the
traditional way you can multiply by
lines but I'm going to teach you a
different way so we look at the number
13 the first digit is 1 so we're going
to write the number 12 one time the next
digit is 3 so we're going to write the
number 12 3 times but we're going to
shift it over one spot because the 3 is
the next digit so we write the number 12
3 times now we will add up the column so
on the far right column we have 2 plus 2
plus 2 which is 6 then we go to the
middle column we have 2 plus 1 plus 1
plus 1 which will be 5 so the middle
column we write a 5 and in the final
column on the Left we just have a 1 so
we're going to write a 1 and that's it
156 is going to be our answer
we can do another example 123 times 321
the first digit that we're multiplying
by is 3 so we're going to write the
number 123 3 times 1 below each other
the next digit that we're multiplying by
is 2 so we're going to write 123 2 times
but we shifted over once because it's
the next digit and finally we have the
last digit which is 1 so we shift over
one more spot and we write 123 one more
time on the column on the far right we
just have a 3 so we're going to write a
3 in the next column we have a 3 plus a
3 plus a 2 which is 8 so in this column
we're going to write an 8 the middle
column is going to have a lot of digits
so we add up 3 3 times 2 - x + 1 one
time and putting that all together we
get 14 we're going to write the 14 that
one goes in the next column and this is
part of the trick we will add up that
one as part of the next column so we
have three ones and three twos which
altogether make nine and our final
column is going to be three ones which
is three so we have three nine four
eight three and that's our answer our
answer is thirty nine thousand four
hundred and eighty-three
let's do an example that includes the
digit zero 221 times 103 the first digit
we're multiplying by is 1 so we write
221 one time the next digit is a zero so
instead of writing 221 one column over
we simply skip the column so when we get
to the next digit which is three we have
to shift over two spots so we write 221
three times but we've shifted it over
two spots and now we go ahead and we add
up each column on the far right we have
three in the next column we have 2 plus
2 plus 2 which is 6 then we go to the
next column which is 1 plus 2 3 times so
that gets a 7 and our final two columns
are easy we just have one digit in each
so we have a 2 and the second to last
column and finally we have a 2 and
that's gonna be our answer 20 2763 so
it's kind of a different way to multiply
numbers and it's pretty easy I hope you
like this video please subscribe to my
channel you can support me on patreon to
get exclusive rewards catch me on my
blog line your decisions on Twitter at
pressure Locker and you can get my books
listed on my website